well let's do this let's let's jump to
the next big story that we saw today
that we got to talk about
and i think it i think this this fits in
a lot of what we're saying this is uh
from deadline
gina carano hits back announces new
movie project with ben shapiro's the
daily wire
they can't cancel us if we don't let
them you know why this you know why they
canceled her
and this plays in a lot of what we're
saying because she's defiant and because
she was getting famous
so i don't i don't want to name any of
these celebrities in the past but if i
were to tell you
that there were outspoken celebrities
defying the war machine
in in decades past you know you
understand the war machine hated that
they hated the fact that celebrities
rose to power whether rock stars or
movie stars or whatever
and then use that activism to defy their
plans
you end up now with in many instances
you have the celebrities just toeing the
line of the establishment elites
and playing along is very very smart
make sure the celebrities in hollywood
and the music industry can only agree
with the authoritarianism otherwise
you'll get people rising up defying you
and then you've got a real problem
because these are charismatic people
when they become famous right
one of the reasons to become famous gina
carano was speaking out saying don't
demonize your neighbor
she was she was speaking out saying
don't bully people you can't tell me
what to do that's defiance
they had to say that they to say you're
out see they don't have to
arrest you or lock you up they're using
economic power
they'll threaten to take your job away
your comfort your livelihood
and it works the problem now i'm really
interested how this plays out because
the daily wire
has the as a movie division now they did
the movie run hide fight
and they they immediately i guess hit up
gina
and they've announced they're doing a
movie together so uh
gina carano said the daily wire is
helping make one of my dreams
to develop and produce my own film come
true i cried out and my prayer was
answered
i am sending out a direct message of
hope to everyone living in fear of
cancellation by the totalitarian
mob i have only just begun using my
voice which is now freer than ever
before
and i hope it inspires others to do the
same they can't cancel us
if we don't let them love it you know
what's fascinating about this
the other day we were talking luke and i
think you were saying she's probably you
know going through a lot with
being cancelled booted off uta
i actually was like i don't know she
seems really tough you know mma fighter
she was probably more angry and
like agitated like oh i'm i'm gonna i'm
gonna fight and we're gonna do this
turns out she's behind the scenes
planning her next major move which only
escalated her stardom yeah even more
famous she also tweeted out today quote
this is just the beginning
welcome to the rebellion awesome energy
awesome vibe
there's some other things happening
behind the scenes i don't want to
mention but uh
great person and that's the spirit you
need to have because if you have the
spirit of
i'm so sorry why'd that i know please
let me have my job back you're utterly
destroyed
and you let them win you let them have
your powers don't let them have your
power
and and and you could come out on top of
this i have the perfect analogy
the perfect analogy see uh you've got uh
some celebrities and after the emperor
declares unlimited power and blasts mace
window out the window they drop to their
knees in front of the woke mob and go
i will do anything you say losers yeah
i mean i i just i you know watching
revenge of the sith you've all seen it
yeah because gina chrono's in star wars
you know we got to do star wars
reference i love demanding i just i just
watch revenge of the sith
and i just want a scene where anakin
just
kills the emperor just just yeah
finishes him off we should remake it
when he drops to his knees and says i'll
do whatever you say i'm like
oh it's so pathetic but it's the movie
right yeah i'd love for him to just be
like
you know mace is fighting the emperor
and then he and then i imagine this
i finally got that scene i always wanted
to see anakin say
no to the empire to the to the emperor
to the empire
gina carano on star wars working for
disney
literally like the empire of media and
they
declared unlimited power do as you're
told and she said no
i will not do whatever you say and left
well awesome man
this is the crazy part because the spin
by the mainstream media is very
interesting there was an article by the
independent
that was titled gina carrano's
mandalorian exit
proves cancel culture doesn't exist
despite what her fans say i had to
double click this because i saw a
screenshot i was like no wait this can't
be real
this is someone just goofing i literally
have to put in that title just to see it
to believe it
they have this article talking about how
there is no cancel culture it doesn't
exist
two plus two equals five just keep doing
what you're told
absolutely crazy i met gina carano about
13 years ago i had a show on spike tv
with her then boyfriend kit cope and she
was the nicest person
she was so nice and she's always
succeeded in everything she's done
so i don't know why this would be any
different and
you know disney has its own dark history
so for them to judge
anybody on any of that and you know when
you discuss a holocaust it's a very
delicate situation we all have jewish
friends and it's very sensitive
and you have to respect that for sure
but it's like if we don't
understand history we're doomed to
repeat she was
she said don't demonize your neighbor it
didn't say republican and say democrat
it didn't say it said don't demonize
your neighbor
i had a family that died in the camps
she gets a pass everyone gets a pass
it doesn't matter we should you're all
right
you should be able to talk about it this
is a one-way this is a one-way river
this water flows in one direction check
out this story from the san francisco
chronicle
a black lives matter mask shut down the
girl and the fig
it's a restaurant it's a wine uh
restaurant i believe
showing the high stakes for restaurants
that stand on the sidelines the famed
wine country restaurant said a blm mask
violated its uniform policy
but for a younger generation disengaging
is no longer acceptable
what is that what is this if you are an
employee
at taco bell because this happened and
you're wearing a black lives matter mask
in violation of company policy and they
try to fire you for your politics
the woke mob attacks the business and
the business hires them back
in this instance we have this this wine
country restaurant
a woman wanted to wear a mask i guess or
employee want to wear a mask they said
no
so the woke mob goes after the business
it's
always in the direction of the cult if
their cult is winning
that's all that matters gina carano was
defiant she resisted
so they get rid of her these restaurants
the business itself
was resisting the cult so they go for
the business it doesn't matter it goes
in one direction
you must support the cult period
otherwise they'll destroy you but i tell
you this
all of the cowards who refuse to speak
up well when they come for you you will
regret it
because you have your chance now to
speak up and be defiant and i i love
what the daily wire is doing by the way
because this is how you win
building culture make movies yes make
movies inspire people yeah cool stuff
build your own website
i was talking a bunch of friends of mine
recently in the past day or so because
of what happened
and a lot of them are telling me like
dude i wish i could you know do
something and speak out but i'll get
fired
and i'm like bro don't say anything
political
just make something cool and inspire
people to hang out with you
and then they will be surrounded by free
loving individuals
that's what you need to do so make
movies hire gina carano do a new
do it do a new series well another thing
people really need to realize is that
they're going to come
for you whether you like it or not for
just maybe even your thoughts in the
future
as we found out today from even
instagram as they announced that they
are going to start banning people
for what they say in private dms your
private messages are now being snooped
through
being scanned by instagram and if
there's any quote hate speech in there
they will ban you for even things you
don't publish they've been scanning your
messages for ages
go back through your history and find
stuff now retroactive enforcement
they've done that too
youtube did it yeah youtube did it for
me i got banned for a video like that
was almost three or four years old
two times that they've done that to me
they've taken me out
you know here's the thing dude we you
have to understand it's like
what is what is the platform what are
the rules either you play by their rules
or you get off and like people think
that's like
ah it's like people from like 2000s
we were we all had our own websites
that's where it's going geocities bro
yeah remember geocities in the 90s yeah
you you went on you signed up you had
your own website
people would just build their own thing
yep and if you were like how did you
find someone's content information well
you get a business card with their
website on it
then we invent that then social social
uh media was invented
you know the first social media website
classmates.com
is that what you used yeah that was the
first one yeah legit first one then
friendster
no it was a little interesting you
journal and live journal were considered
to be the precursor to friendster
where people were linking with users and
posting things and sharing their
journals yeah yeah
so a bunch of my friends were using you
journal and live journal
and then friendster happened and
friendster was where you actually had a
list of your friends
people could look at friendsterman and
then myspace was better
tim take the pillow money buy my space
take my space is totally different now
though it's not even a lot of timber
likes to loan it
i think i think you could give for 30
mil dude a lot of people were saying
that myspace they're like let's all go
back to myspace
yeah and it's like it's not even it
doesn't mean it doesn't work that way
anymore it's like
it's a music website now it's not a
social media minds is probably better
technology anyway and it's open
yeah definitely we just need to build
stuff right this is the point the reason
why
i think what ben shapiro is doing the
daily wire is the smartest and best
thing possible
it's peaceful it's persuasive it's
resourceful there's no violence
but it's so powerful they're freaking
out already smearing you know what i
love
ben shapiro daily wire puts out run hide
fight this new movie
right it's about a school shooting and i
guess some of the reviewers are saying
it's kind of like die hard
like an intense action movie the rotten
tomatoes score
what do you think it is what do you
think the critics gave it uh like uh a
10.
25 what do you think the audience gave
it 99
93 of course it's ideological
there was another what was that movie
with bruce willis you guys remember
where he his wife gets killed and he
goes buy a bunch of guns
what was that movie called i don't
remember i can't remember what it was
called
but i but it was another one of these
movies where the audience score was
ridiculously high because a really
enjoyable film is a popcorn flick it's
bruce wills with guns taking out bad
guys gotta love it right i love die hard
and it was like he was a family man and
he wanted like he like hit a gun under a
desk and like the bad guy comes back in
and his daughter's hiding under the
under the stairs and then he hits it and
the gun comes out and he
just narrowly survives it was awesome
critics
what was it death wish that's right and
the critics hated it they were like oh
this is a gun nut masturbation film
kid you not that was one of the reviews
and then the audience was like that was
really enjoyable i was on the edge of my
seat the whole time good job bruce
willis
it's not it's not it's not casablanca or
anything it's not this great
movie of great history it's an
entertainment it
you you watch it at the theater you have
some popcorn you smile you laugh you're
on the edge you see whoa
and then you go home and that's it you
maybe get it on dvd or download it on
amazon i guess or subscribe
does anyone listen to critics anymore i
feel like they they
totally whiffed on everything and the
new generation's like i'll either watch
it if i like it
or not i'm not gonna yeah but some guy's
never done it it changed when we could
get the crowd to review stuff like steam
video games you'll have like game stop
magazine or whatever will come out and
be like nine out of ten explosive and
it's one guy that works
and then you go to the steam reviews and
there's like 70 000 reviews 73
overall and you're like okay it's a 73
overall this is why i decided to launch
a pillow company
yeah i guess i'm sorry our pillow yes
and the mai
is crossed off oh some somebody tweeted
at me they were like tim you didn't
start a pillow company
you started a teespring campaign that
sells pillows and i said
we started a spring campaign that sells
pillows but uh so the plan is now i
ordered a bunch of burlap sacks
and we're gonna pour packing peanuts
into them and just staple them shut
and uh the gag is they're totally brutal
pillows like the
worst and most uncomfortable thing
you'll ever sleep on
but it's the right ideology so you have
to buy it that's that's that's
don't forget dude made in america is
this the arm pillow
yes it's going to be a burlap with
memory foam you could probably say oh
wow
whoa what's the perfect pillow for
couples no no no no no no no
yeah the point is the point is a
burlap sack full of packing peanuts
stapled shut is garbage
but people will buy it because it
supports their tribe
that's what's going on with movies and
video games why is david hogg starting a
pillow company in the first place
it's every who i can't remember who said
they're on the show they said
every pillow company is competing with
my pillow they'd all
love to put him out of business because
they all are certain
yeah yeah serta makes pillows so the
only reason to start a pillow company
the only reason david hogg would do it
is because it's a tribal virtue signal
now look more power to him which him
success if he sells pillows fantastic
and so i jokingly am going to start one
mocking the whole idea i mean we have
the hour pillow go to timcast.com
click the shop button and you can buy
the gag pillow from teespring but we're
legit
i swear i ordered burlap sax we're going
to film this
and we're going to run a commercial
vision uh we're running this i'm not
kidding i am going to run this on prime
time
it's happening and i'm looking over
prices and it's going to be very
expensive
but i think selling burlap sacks full of
packing peanuts with an excellent profit
margin
this is like a coke idea without the
coke well listen listen listen here's
the best part
if people buy burlap sacks full of
packing peanuts for pennies on the
dollar
and i sell them for 50 bucks each i'm
gonna make mad profit communism
yeah let me ask you who do you think has
weirder who got weirder
who got famous off a weirder thing kim
kardashian or david hawk
ooh uh well the thing about david hogg
is that he's
he's in a political space and with all
due respect man i mean
the story and what happened in parkland
is horrifying it's horrifying so i got
i got i got no beef i got no issue i
think i did more power to david hogg
he's got his opinions i think he's a
young naive kid i think a lot of
a lot of them are and i think they there
are a lot of powerful special interests
that want gun control that were willing
to prop that up
i mean look kim kardashian is a
marketing master
i mean i have no disrespect to her at
all you you go
boo i i'm not complaining about it's
just like weird things to get famous off
of that's i mean to be completely honest
people people get people get famous for
very strange that was weird yeah and
people if you look
you look back in history fame used to be
negative like almost always negative
you know the people who got famous got
famous for you know being murderers or
whatever
robin hood i mean he's not a real he
wasn't famous
in life yeah i don't i don't think he's
actually real but uh
you think about the the people who are
famous back in the wild west and they
were all basically scoundrels
they're all crooked for some reason or
another fame is a weird thing it's just
a story that you hear look at dillinger
he's robbing banks
and he's famous capone al capone i mean
you have you have movie stars eventually
coming in and fame became more of this
weird sideshow kind of thing yeah
infamous was a was a pretty popular
phrase back in the day but it's mass
media change
notoriety notoriety basically but look
man look i i got tourists i'll tell you
i'll tell you this
what the reason i brought up all the
pillow stuff especially with you know
making my own pillow company and then
david hogg it's because this is what
we're seeing right now with the daily
wire
you can't win with when the cultural
institutions have been totally taken
over
by the woke cultists you're you can't
and so they've kicked us out of the
castle
they've said go away what do we do
build our own they've been saying it
over and over again build your own so
okay we'll start doing that now when
many of these you know conservatives
tried launching things like parlor for
instance
they got nuked even gab got nuked in in
the beginning
early on everybody started saying you
can't build your own because they
control all the infrastructure the
financial infrastructure infrastructure
the the
the dns the the servers all that stuff
the hosting
well gab figured it out you're you're
familiar with yeah yeah right
so gab starts building their own
infrastructure the daily wire is now
building their own infrastructure
and so it may have been difficult and
taken some time we are really headed
towards this point
tribal capitalism where people are gonna
be like i need a pillow which pillow
supports my political ideology
and then they'll go buy in you know hogs
pillow you know good pillow and then
conservatives will buy my pillow
i guess i gotta be honest i think
conservatives would just buy the cheaper
pillow that makes the most sense yeah
but it's the tribal and the the tribal
leftists are really gonna go hard for
you know whatever supports their
ideology i think uh the super bowl
really was like overdone with like just
all the progressivism and all the woke
stuff and i think the nfl better watch
itself because
i mean say whatever you want ma'am
america
showed its true colors they put they
they get nobody watches television
okay nobody's involved in everyone's
pulling out this political correctness
stuff
everyone's pulling out the two-party
system they did what they did
they could they controlled which is
where their attention and their money
went
and this whole thing about you know how
the election went and all that stuff
it's it's very interesting
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time